balla Braun  there was nothing normal about the girl  she grew into the August kekulé I was  like thank you mr. Bryant I'm here on  urgent business difference obviously the  complaint what come here  I can't forgive this you have wondered  everything nature sounds like a we get  along so somebody in black just Norma  serenading like one month on today  because I'm home I can insert any garden  what does it you do when you're not  murdering Clark I would have time to  tidy up again I think that's what Hitler  said about Europe what you're doing by  the way  [Music]  mr. Isaac if I were you you might even  help me other way like a god how do we  keep interest from April to October Reed  Reed would become please drop me the  other day in the library let those  pieces pick I am kind of a bad day will  be like fear my birthday this is how our  life is moon came clean  totally blank canvas tries to create  your own mouth  personal items he had a passion for life  a monkey thank you  you